una jornada contra la violencia en los
eeuu como un minuto de silencio donde se
produjo una de las matanzas más
sangrientas de los últimos meses
recordaron a las víctimas cada nombre de
los ultimados resonaba como una
advertencia contra el odio y andrei
mcnew
el homenaje se llevó a cabo a unas horas
de la reapertura del escenario de la
masacre el supermercado tops de buffalo
new york el lugar donde murieron tres
afroamericanos y tres resultaron heridos
ahora se levanta como un símbolo de
resiliencia
for the open en la forma en que todos se
han unido para la apertura de nuestros
tops en jefferson avenue es una prueba
positiva de que el amor vence al odio
pizza
y
después tomaremos este lugar de tragedia
y en los días las semanas los meses y
los años venideros será un ejemplo
nacional y mundial de un lugar de
triunfo este jueves un tribunal federal
acusó al tirador peyton graydon de 14
crímenes de odio y 13 delitos
relacionados con el porte y uso de armas
el fiscal general de los estados unidos
reaccionó el departamento de justicia
reconoce plenamente la amenaza que
representa la violencia supremacista
blanca para la seguridad del pueblo y la
democracia estadounidense mientras tanto
en highland park desde el pasado 4 de
julio un hombre armado disparó contra
quienes celebraban el día de la
independencia matando a siete personas
una artista montó una obra para
conmemorar a las víctimas y para exigir
una nueva legislación de control de
armas
juan esta comunidad está hablando con
una voz clara y consistente de que
estamos pidiendo un control de armas
sensato por cein
el hecho de que estamos combatiendo con
tiras de tela hilo y tiza
estamos de rodillas rogando por un
cambio aquí los recientes actos de
violencia armada en el país incluyendo
el de yuval de texas llevaron al
congreso a aprobar la legislación
federal más importante en décadas para
el control de armas sin embargo el
presidente de baidu ha dicho que la
iniciativa no es lo suficientemente
ambiciosa